Hallo, Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon und der Podcast ist ja etwas ganz Besonderes, denn man kann im Podcast sich unterhalten. Man kann vielleicht Kontroverses von sich geben, aber es passiert in der Regel nicht, dass es dann den Shitstorm oder so gibt. Also nur in ganz seltenen Fällen werden da mal irgendwelche Audioclips geschnitten. Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, wir würden jetzt hier zusammen einen Podcast machen und ich würde dir sagen, weißt du, bei Kulturveranstaltungen sollte die Maskenpflicht nicht wieder eingeführt werden. Nicht nur ist die Maske ja eine große Einschränkung, es kann auch jeder selbst entscheiden, ob er sich dem Risiko aussetzt. Und ich sitze ständig neben maskenlosen uralten Klassik-Konzertbesuchern. Und ich empfinde das als Einschränkung, drei bis fünf Stunden eine Maske dadurch zu atmen, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Oper genieße. Denn, um es mal ein bisschen problemisch zu sagen, ich spüre noch was. Im Pausen-Foyer werden ohnehin alle die Maske ausziehen, um was zu essen, zu trinken. Und im Kino wird man auch Popcorn nicht verbieten. So, jetzt stell dir vor, das, was ich dir jetzt gerade gesagt habe, war abgelesen, das waren nämlich zwei Tweets von mir gestern. So in leichter Variation gerade abgelesen. Dies hat dazu geführt, dass ich regelrecht geschlachtet wurde auf Twitter gestern. Also ein paar hundert Kommentare sind es, glaube ich, inzwischen und Rukus und was es alles gibt. Also es wurde so getan von vielen Leuten, also nicht alles, haben auch viele Leute das geliked. Aber es wurde wirklich von der No-Zero-Covid-Fraktion wirklich so getan, als hätte ich dazu aufgerufen, alle Katzenbabys totzuschlagen oder so. Es ist ganz absurd, auch dann eine Professorin aus Trier, Andrea Geier, die dann auch sagt, ja ich wusste ja gar nicht, dass man Opern durch die Nase hört und so wird das dann alles noch kommentiert. So als sei die Maske auch gar keine Einschränkung, als sei das nur etwas Eingebildetes. Und ich dachte, ich setze einfach etwas ab, um noch mal deutlich zu machen, uns ist die Kultur wichtig, die Kultur hat jetzt schon Zuschauer-Schwund, wenn eine Maskenpflicht wieder kommt, dann sieht es ganz trübe aus. Das sagen Kinobetreiber, das sagen Konzertveranstalter, alle sagen das, aber nein, es ist auf Twitter nicht möglich, solche Diskurse auch nur zu führen. Und da ist auch nichts evidenzbasiert oder sonst was, sondern alle drehen am Rad. Und ich darf daran erinnern, Impfung haben wir dreifach, vielleicht dann irgendwann vierfach das Versprechen damit war, dass wir dann wieder das Leben zurückbekommen. Und wer eine Maske als Einschränkung empfindet, ist nicht vollkommen verrückt. Und das Schöne ist, ich sage noch in diesem Tweet, ich sitze die ganze Zeit neben 80-Jährigen und die haben keine Maske an. Und ich gehe am selben Tag dann gestern, denn ich befinde mich dann nicht, wenn ich sowas getötet habe den ganzen Tag auf Twitter. Ich gehe dann noch in ein Konzert. Cantoria, Cantoria, ein Ensemble, ein Vokal-Ensemble aus Spanien, sang Sakralmusik aus dem 16. Jahrhundert. Ganz, ganz großartig. Und wir sitzen da neben mir, eine Lehrerin von früher. Und ich erinnerte mich dann, ach ja, die wurde ja damals noch aus der Rente zurückgerufen, um uns noch zu unterrichten, weil da schon ein gewisser Mangel herrschte. Und na ja, man vergisst dann ja auch selbst so die Jahre. Und dann sitzt sie dann da. Und sie war also damals schon über das Rentenalter, über das das eigentliche Alter hinaus hat sie uns dann unterrichtet. Und na ja, das ist ja schon eine Weile her. Und dann saß sie da neben mir und sie sieht blendend aus. Das sagte ich ihr dann auch und dann sagt sie ja für meine 82 fühle ich mich auch topfit und alles. Und dann denke ich unglaublich und dann sagt sie ja ja sie hätte ja jetzt auch mal Corona gehabt. Aber das war halb so wild gewesen. Sie sitzt natürlich ohne Maske da zwei Tage vorher. Bin ich in einem anderen Klassik Konzert treffe dort eine Dame aus der Koblenzer Kulturszene, von der mir berichtet wurde. Sie hatte ziemlich hart Corona im April, war dann im Theater, hatte da fast einen Zusammenbruch, wurde dann geradezu in die Loge getragen. Aber was gibt es für den Opernfan schöneres als in der Loge notfalls zu sterben? Und auch sie kam mir schon fröhlich mit dem Weißweinglas entgegen bei dieser Konzertveranstaltung. Und auch sie saß natürlich ohne Maske da und auch sie geht auf die 80 zu. Ich will nur mal sagen, in diesen ganzen Konzerten, den ich sitze, ist das so. Und ich würde vielleicht diesen Leuten, die da auf Twitter so hyperventilieren, einfach mal empfehlen, hinaus ins Leben zu gehen, vielleicht auf ein Kammerkonzert oder es so zu machen wie du, wirklich sagen, jetzt geht es in die Masse hinein.
Ja, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig. Also, wir sind ja hier nicht bei Lanz und Brecht. Das heißt, ich wusste von nichts, was du mir erzählst, sondern du hast mir einfach kurz gesagt, ich muss kurz über Twitter reden. Ich habe weder gelesen noch nachgelesen, was dir geantwortet wurde, und möchte aber sagen, lieber Wolfgang, ich gehe gern mit dir all in, denn ja, ich glaube mittlerweile auch, es gibt keinen schöneren Ort zu sterben als in der Loge eines Konzerts, das vielleicht sogar noch läuft. Diese Feinheiten sollte man jetzt schon noch mal erwähnen. Mein Buch handelt auch ein bisschen vom Tod. Ich wollte es natürlich nicht ganz so debrisch schreiben für die jungen Leute, aber Leute denken ab 80 doch anders übers Leben und auch über die guten Seiten des Lebens, die nämlich noch knapp werden in diesem Alter. Es ist nicht so, dass man dann irgendwie sagt, ich würde gerne noch zehn Jahre mich so durchschleppen, statt irgendwie eine Woche noch mal Halligalli zu erleben. Viele würden dann doch für Halligalli optieren.
Meine Nachbarn, 84, fahren jetzt auf Kreuzfahrt. Und wenn ich denen sagen würde, ich ziehe bald wieder Maske im Theater an, um euch zu schützen, dann würden die meinen, ich hätte nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank. Ich will mich jetzt, glaube ich, nur noch mit 80 und 90 Jahren umgeben.
Viele denken gerade, wir haben nicht die Tassen im Schrank. Aber ich will es ausdrücklich sagen, wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht. Und Dietmar Bartsch hat es im Bundestag zu Recht damals gesagt, das Sterben in den Heimen war vielleicht das dunkelste Kapitel Deutschlands in den Nachkriegsjahren. Und das ist fast wörtwörtlich zitiert. Und es stimmt genau, es ist ein ganz dunkles Kapitel. Denn sehr viele Menschen wurden nicht vor die Wahl gestellt, ob sie noch mal ihre Familie sehen oder dafür vielleicht noch, sie wissen auch nicht, ein paar Monate länger leben. Und wir können so ungefähr sagen, grob gerundet, alle hätten für die Familie optiert. Aber es war ihnen versagt wegen irgendeiner Politik, die solche religiös verpeilten Typen wie Jens Spahn machen, die wirklich wenig vom Leben verstehen. Was man ja auch in vielen anderen Bereichen, wo man so einen Blick hat bei ihm, heraus sehen kann. Und ja, dein Appell ins Leben zu gehen, unbedingt. Wir waren ja nun in Belgien. Das ist nicht Deutschland, das fällt einem sofort auf. Denn man vergisst seine Maske im Hotel und denkt, wir sind ja gar nicht in Deutschland, scheiß drauf. Hier kann man ja Bus und Bahn und Taxi und alles fahren. Und dann ist man bei einer Massenveranstaltung, steht unter 50, 60.000 Leuten, die alle des Lebens froh sind, weil sie wissen, dieser Abend heute ist das letzte Mal, dass wir Rammstein live in Europa sehen können. Wusste ja keiner, dass es noch mal das Highlight gibt. Und als allerletztes auf der Alleinwand steht, dass wir sie alle 2023 schon wieder sehen können. Also doppelte Freude sozusagen an so einem Abend. Und in Belgien waren nur Belgien, Belgier und Franzosen. Da waren kaum Deutsche, wir haben jedenfalls kaum welche gehören. Und in der Hinsicht war die Stimmung auch entsprechend. Und die Rammsteiner fahren danach auch nicht nach Hause nach Deutschland, sondern die machen erst mal Urlaub überall auf der Welt. Ohne deren Sicht. Ich weiß nicht genau, was hier in Deutschland los ist, aber ich werde nachher mit ein bisschen, und ich will es ausdrücklich sagen, und ich meine es genau so, angeekelter, aber Freude nachlesen, was du für Kommentare bekommen hast. Denn ich mache mir langsam so wirklich ein bisschen Sorgen um diese Stimmung hier in Deutschland. Es ist komisch.
Es ist besorgniserregend.
Dieses Corona-Thema scheint doch tiefschirvende Spuren hinterlassen zu haben. Es ist eine grundsätzliche Nervosität da. Ich hoffe, ich kann mit meinem Buch ein bisschen Aufklärung treiben. Denn ich glaube, hier liegt auch sehr viel Vermeidungsverhalten einfach in der Luft im Sinne von ich wünsche mir so sehr einen handelnden Start beim Klima, bei meinen Mietpreisen, bei meiner Altersvorsorge. Kriege ich alles nicht? Na dann wenigstens bei Corona. So und dann wird alles da so reingebuttert. Diese These ist eine meiner Lieblingsthesen vorgetragen zuerst von Matthias, der auch diese Musik für diesen Podcast gemacht hat. Und ich glaube, sie wird immer wahrer. Wir sehen immer mehr davon. Die Evidenz nimmt irgendwie zu. Es ist komisch in Deutschland. Ich hoffe, jeder, der sie braucht, kann sich seine Freiräume nehmen. Denn man kann mir diesen, ich will jetzt nicht Covidioten sagen, aber man kann mir diesen Leuten nicht länger gemeinsam Gesellschaft machen, ist so mein Eindruck. Also es wird brenzlig.
Die Spaltung geht auch in diese Richtung. Das ist ganz furchtbar zu sehen. Und bei Twitter habe ich den Eindruck, ja, es gibt natürlich diese Corona-Leugner, mit denen man nichts zu tun haben will, mit denen man aber gleich in Verbindung gebracht wird, nachdem man sich dreimal geimpft hat und sonst an alles hält. Und dann mal sagt, vielleicht sollte man eine Maskenpflicht nicht wieder einführen, die also wohlgemerkt geradeaus gesetzt ist. Dann wird man zum Teil als Faschist bezeichnet. Also ist alles gestern passiert. Ich meine, ich habe ein dickes Fell, mir macht das nichts aus. Ist es eher für mich, dass ich darauf blicke und sage, wie soll eine Gesellschaft in Zukunft aussehen? Also ich finde es eher besorgniserregend und erkenne auch eine enorme Heuchelei darin. Denn natürlich sind auch all diese Leute, die das die ganze Zeit da twittern, gerade im Urlaub und in Restaurants, auf Festivals, auf dem CSD, machen Langstreckenflüge, was auch immer. Und wenn die das alles so ernst nehmen würden, dann würden sie das ja alles sich versagen. Das tun sie aber nicht. Es ist außerdem ja auch ein Unsinn zu behaupten, jetzt im Sommer sind ja alle draußen. Jetzt war es ja sehr heiß wieder in der vergangenen Woche. Ich war da zufällig, weil ich einen Freund zu Gast hatte in Koblenz tagsüber unterwegs. Kein Mensch ist natürlich bei dieser Hitze auf der Straße. Die Menschen sind drin. Restaurants und Bars werben inzwischen damit. Hier ist alles klimatisiert. Kommen sie rein. Und ich finde das besorgniserregend, dass von den seriösen, mitte, bürgerlichen, linken, linksliberalen Journalisten nicht eine sinnvolle Kritik an Corona-Maßnahmen artikuliert wird. Gerade um auch jenen den Teppich unter den Füßen wegzuziehen, die behaupten, man könnte ja nichts mehr sagen oder so. Dass man jetzt mal nach Verhältnismäßigkeit fragt, dass man gewisse Dinge in Frage stellt, dass man es mal mit anderen Ländern vergleicht, dass man nicht immer nur einen deutschen Sonderweg wählt. Aber bei Twitter habe ich den Eindruck, da sind wirklich nur noch Lars Weißbrot und ich, die mal hin und wieder den Kopf hinhalten und dann sich so ein bisschen vorwagen. Und ich verstehe das nicht, dass es da keinen Aufschrei von Medienleuten bei manchen Dingen gibt, auch dass jetzt einfach so eine neue Kategorie frisch geimpft eingeführt wird. Das ist für mich nicht nachvollziehbar. Und auch dieses Solidaritätsargument zieht für mich bei kulturellen Veranstaltungen nicht. Ich kenne ja und begegne ihnen ja ständig Leute, die eher von Corona stark betroffen sind. Sehr alte, sehr übergewichtige Leute, die ohne Maske da sitzen. Und dann gibt es ja noch so etwas wie Hochrisikopatienten. Also für die wirklich eine Grippe eine große Gefahr ist. Egal, ob es jetzt eine Corona-Grippe ist oder etwas anderes. Die gehen ohnehin nicht in einen geschlossenen, fensterlosen Raum mit 1000 Leuten und sehen sich drei Stunden lang Konzerte an. Das ist also Quatsch, dass man glaubt, jetzt man schützt sich da vor denen. Ich habe eher den Eindruck, die Leute, die da die ganze Zeit von Solidarität und so reden, bilden sich diese Solidarität zum einen ein. Und zum anderen ist das ein guter Ausweg für sie, selbst nichts zu machen, weil sie zu Hause bleiben müssen. Und wir wissen auch, dass es Veranstaltungen gibt, wo eine Maskenpflicht auch gar nicht mehr irgendwie zu was führt. Also wir waren ja gemeinsam in Frankfurt in der Oper. Da hast du ja selbst gesagt, mein Gott, da sind immer viele Leute auf der Bühne. Ja, da sind dann mit Chor und auch 80 Leute auf der Bühne, die singen, die also keine Maske tragen können. Ja, da fliegen die Aerosole bis in die letzte Reihe natürlich. Aber das ist dann so und das das geben wir auch ein. Und ich finde das wirklich schlimm. Und ich finde auch, dass wir da einen Mittelweg finden müssen, der leugnet alles und was weiß ich und Impfgegnern. Und dann gibt es aber auch einfach Menschen, die eine vernünftige Stimme haben und sagen, ist das eigentlich verhältnismäßig oder ist das eigentlich noch gerade logisch, was wir da tun? Und bei diesen Kulturveranstaltungen, ich werde ja auch einen Text im Salon jetzt gleich vorstellen, der nicht von irgendeinem Hochkulturmenschen handelt, weil mir ja auch immer dann so ein Snobismus unterstellt wird. Ja, Opa, hahaha. Werd dich mal vorstellen, wo jemand sagt, was eigentlich verloren geht, wenn die Kulturveranstaltungen nicht mehr besucht werden.
Jetzt hast du nochmal die Corona-Grippe genannt, begrifflich. Das triggert natürlich einige, das will ich noch mal kurz auf. Corona ist ja keine Grippe, aber der Vergleich bietet sich ja trotzdem an. Schon vor dem Zeitpunkt, an dem wir Impfungen hatten, hat ja Drosten diese ganz große Sterblichkeitsstudie aufgegriffen. Für unter 45-Jährige war Corona, was die Sterblichkeit angeht, nie schlimmer als eine Grippe. Mit der Impfung ist es natürlich nochmal weit abgeschwächter. Was wieder mehr in die Richtung geht, ist das Solidaritätsargument, wenn überhaupt diskutieren sollten. Da haben wir aber lange verpasst. Ganz am Anfang, die meisten erinnern sich, Masken helfen ja gar nicht, der Lappen auf den Mund. Wie man Gomory sagte. Dann haben wir festgestellt, die Masken helfen ganz schön gut. Aber immer nur unter diesem Fremdschutzargument. Jeder tut so, als hätte er es und schützt dann die anderen. Mittlerweile haben wir Masken, mit denen man sich sehr gut selbst schützen kann. Damit kommt man auch durch die Oper, wenn 80 Leute auf der Bühne singen. Denn diese drei Stunden halten die Masken alle aus. Also niemanden bleibt irgendetwas versagt.
Wir sind ja nicht für ein Maskenverbot.
Ja, genau. Der Selbstschutz, jeder soll natürlich einen Fahrradhelm tragen und ein funktionierendes Licht an seinem Auto und so weiter. Manche Sachen sind Pflicht, andere sind eben nicht. Aber hilfreich ist vieles und das kann man dann auch entsprechend nutzen. Ich fände es irgendwie amüsant, wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich alle nochmal, also nicht wie im Podcast so, sondern so grundsätzlich diese Lauterbach kommt ins Amt und sagt, ich führe dieses Haus streng nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien, so als wäre das vorher nicht passiert. Und dann kriegen wir jetzt so langsam diese ganzen E-Mails mal aufgeschlüsselt, wer hat hier wen irgendwie informiert. Und ja, also das RKI hat immer ganz toll informiert und evidenzbasiert und so weiter. Aber dann versackten die Informationen irgendwo im Ministerium. Und dann ist man so an soziale Probleme gestoßen, wie wir das letzte Mal schon vom NASA-Chefingenieur gehört haben. Und am Ende hat das alles mit fast nichts zu tun, außer mit sozialem Unvermögen, durch auch vielleicht ein bisschen soziale Inkompetenz an der Spitze so eines Bundesministeriums. Und wenn man sich dann ganz aktuell anschaut, wie diese Empfehlung von Lauterbach zur vierten Impfung zustande kam und dann auch mehrtens öffentlich sich auch, also nicht nur da widersprach im Sinne von viel hilft, viel ist vielleicht nicht der richtige Ansatz, sondern vielleicht sollte man auch wirklich wieder evidenzbasiert zurück, dass Lauterbach jetzt sozusagen gegen sich selber von vor zwei Jahren da irgendwie ankämpft und so. Das ist schon irgendwie amüsant, aber da kommt man gar nicht so richtig hin, das jetzt mal zu diskutieren. Obwohl das da eben auch triftig wäre bei der Frage, wie werden wir eigentlich regiert. Stattdessen verhaspeln sich alle und wir auch so ein bisschen, wir reden auch schon wieder über Corona, als ob das ein Thema wäre, wollen wir ja gar nicht.
Ich kann noch was über die Bahn sagen. Ich habe da noch mal einen Vorschlag und zwar hatte ich wie gesagt Besuch und dieser Besuch sollte nach dem Konzert, wollte nach dem Konzert dann nach Frankfurt mit dem Zug und eigentlich mit dem Regionalticket, aber dann fuhr doch kein Regionalzug mehr. Wir waren nach 22 Uhr, also wurde ein ICE gebucht. Dieser kostete dann 32 Euro von Koblenz bis Frankfurt. Das ist ja ein enormer Betrag, 2. Und dann brachte ich ihn zum Bahnhof und machte dann den großen Fehler, dass ich einfach sagte, ja, alles Gute und fuhr los. Aber einfach so in dem, na ja, dann kommt ja der Zug in 8 Minuten. Und am nächsten Tag schrieb ich und gut angekommen, ja, aber 140 Minuten Verspätung. Also saß er von 0 Uhr bis tief in die Morgenstunden am Bahnhof dort rum. Und dann gibt es ja irgendwie so komische Rückerstattung, die Hälfte oder den Fahrpreis. Und dann haben sie dann Formular. Wir sind ja Fans von Preisen, Preiseregeln, ja Dinge. Wir sagst ja immer, wir brauchen mal wirklich den CO2-Preis. Müssen wir mal machen, so wie die FDP sagt.
Wie es in der FDP-Pokal steht.
Und dann machen wir mal 280 Euro und dann gucken wir mal, was dann passiert. So, und ich würde auch sagen, wie kriegt man die Bahn pünktlich? Wie gibt es da wirklich einen Anreiz? Es muss ordentlich Geld kosten. Und mein Vorschlag ist jetzt einfach, die ersten zehn Minuten, das ist Karenzzeit, da kann die Bahn machen, was sie will. Aber alles, was darüber hinausgeht, da sollte nicht nur das Ticket dann erstattet werden, sondern jede Minute Verspätung bekommt der Fahrgast zwei Euro. Und da wollen wir doch mal sehen, was dann passiert. Denn es ist ja wirklich so, da wird dir jemanden der halbe Tag kaputt gemacht, wenn man dann morgens in Frankfurt ankommt. Das tut ja richtig weh. Und vielleicht muss man geschäftlich noch was machen und ist dazu dann nicht in der Lage. Also ich würde mal sagen, zwei Euro ab Minute 10 pro Minute. Und dann werden wir mal gucken, wie sich die Bahn entwickelt.
Ja, das wäre wahnsinnig wünschenswert, denn unsere Rückfahrtgeschichte war so, wir sind in Brüssel, fahren ein bisschen mit dem E-Roller rum.
Einen Moment, ich muss dich unterbrechen. Ich habe den Stöpsel nicht drin.
Welchen Schlöpsel? Ach so Kopfrauch?
Ja, so einen Schnitt, das war der Akku, der ist aber jetzt satt sich.
Unsere Rückfahrgeschichte aus Brüssel passt dazu. Wir fahren mit dem E-Roller so durch die Stadt und denken, cool, wir haben noch vier Stunden bis der Zug fährt um mit dem E-Roller. Tolles Tourismus Ding, kommt man ja wirklich weit. Brüssel ist ja auch so eine dreidimensionale Stadt irgendwie, oben, unten und dann in der Mitte auch nochmal. Riesengroß, wir haben es auf Wikipedia gelesen, 180.000 Einwohner, es wirkt aber irgendwie wie 17 Millionen. Naja, wir fahren da also rum und sehen dann, ach, unser Zug fällt aus, cool. Wir können also nicht bis Frankfurt fahren mit dem ICE, stattdessen Thales. Wir steigen also in den Thales ein, der Nächste kommt und denken uns, ja, wenn der Zug ausfällt, kann man ja jeden nehmen, da sind wir ja nicht an unseren Zug gebunden, also nehmen wir den nächsten Thales, sitzen im Thales und dann sagen die, ja, das ist hier so eine Privatbahn, sie können das nicht bei der Deutschen Bahn zurückerstatten lassen, müssen aber erstmal bezahlen. Das heißt, der Zug fällt aus, nicht nur kriegen wir nicht sofort eine Erstattung für die 100 Minuten bis zum nächsten ICE, der übrigens nicht fuhr, also es fuhr in gar keine ICEs mehr, man musste auf den Thales ausweichen, also für alle, die keine Kreditkarte haben, lieber nicht in Brüssel stranden, dann kann man kein Ticket kaufen für den Thales. Dann sitzt man da einfach fest. Naja, man bezahlt also nochmal extra 138 Euro und hofft die ganze Zeit und überlegt sich schon mal, wie kriegen wir das eigentlich zurück und so. Das sind ja auch immer nur so eigene Geschichten. Also man muss extra zahlen, wenn die Deutsche Bahn nicht fährt. Und eine Rückerstattung plus, also eine Rückerstattung im Sinne, wie du es meintest, mit verbrauchter Minuten wird es natürlich da nicht geben. Naja, in deren Sicht alles dramatisch, aber ich will allen nochmal sagen, nächstes Jahr gibt es wieder Rammstein-Konzerte. Wir wissen alle noch nicht so genau, wann. Und Silvester gibt es wohl auch eine große Showse, aber...
Ich habe ja ein Lied, das ich besonders mag von Rammstein, Seemann.
Seemann, ganz alte Schule, sehr gut. Seemann hält ja immer noch, wie so zu sagen, Seemann ist immer noch präsent, weil die ja mit dem Schlauchboot fahren. Die sind ja bei Engel mitten im Publikum und dann fahren sie mit dem Schlauchboot über das Publikum hinweg. Und wir standen so, dass wir auch ein bisschen mithelfen konnten, dass das Schlauchboot vorne ankam. Also in deren Sicht ein Spektakel, das ist ein besonders Gleiches. Ich hatte noch 2019 in Erinnerung, da saß ich auf der Tribüne. Diesmal stand ich unten drin. Und wenn Sonne gespielt wird und die Hälfte des Feuers des ganzen Konzertes wird ungefähr so bei Sonne abgefeuert, ist es eine ganz interessante Erfahrung, die Wärme zu spüren. Es ist nicht nur das Feuer und hell, dass man so ein Panorama von der Tribüne aussieht und dann geht es nach oben weg, sondern man steht unten, macht die Augen zu und denkt, krass, es ist taghell. Und es fühlt sich wirklich an, für diese ganz kurze Momente immer, als ob gerade die Textil-Sonne 12 Uhr mittags auf einen drauf scheint. Also es ist eine zusätzliche physische Erfahrung, mit der ich so nicht gerechnet habe, die entsprechend nochmal richtig reinknallt, weil laut ist es ja ohnehin und so. Und das will ich doch jedem empfehlen, sich das nochmal, wie soll man sagen, das nochmal zu fühlen. Denn wir waren ja eine Woche vorher bei Iron Maiden, und ja, der Dickens entholt dann auch kurz mal so Flammenwerfer raus, einer rechts, einer links und ballert so ein bisschen rum, völlig ohne Sinn und Verstand und man denkt sich so, ja gut, alle wollten mal ihren Spaß haben, er auch. Aber das nochmal zu sehen, was dann die echten Pyrotechniker dahin zaubern, ist unglaublich. Man kann sich wirklich nicht ganz vorstellen, wie intensiv und heiß es dann tatsächlich ist. Also in deren Sicht, großer Jubel, als es hieß. 2023 geht es weiter.
Wir haben einen Hörerkommentar von Janik, der unsere Debatte aufgreift zu Migration und Arbeitskräftemangel. Den kann man jetzt mal abspielen, um mal einen Eindruck aus der unmittelbaren Wirklichkeit zu erhalten.
Ja, und zwar unter der Maßgabe, wie wir einfach so nicht regiert werden. Wir nur darüber plaudern, aber bei manchen das halt wirklich als Problem aufschlägt.
Hallo Wolfgang, Hallo Stefan. Ihr habt bei der letzten Podcastfolge beschrieben, wie das Thema Fachkräftemangel häufig nicht mit dem Gesichtspunkt des demografischen Wandels und auch der Migrationspolitik besprochen wird. Und passend dazu habe ich einen Fall. Ich arbeite im Jugendamt. Ein junger Mann aus dem afrikanischen Raum ist jetzt vor kurzem hier 18 geworden, ist gerade dabei, seinen Realschulabschluss zu machen. Sehr guten Realschulabschluss, spricht die Sprache bereits auch sehr gut, also Deutsch sehr gut. Und ist untergebracht in einer Einrichtung, wo auch Menschen mit Behinderungen leben. Und hat sich zur Aufgabe gemacht, Pfleger zu werden. Also sein Herzenswunsch ist, den Ausbildungsberuf Pflege zu erlernen. Also einen der Berufe, die im Moment sehr rar sind. Und vom Jugendamt geht man dann immer hin und macht dann sogenannte Hilfe-Plan-Gespräche. Schaut, okay, wie viel Geld muss da fließen? Was muss der junge Mann dann einhalten? Und er ist unbegleitet hier. Er hat seine Eltern beide verloren. Die Brüder sind in Europa verstreut. Und deswegen steht ihm jemand zur Seite. Ebenfalls von einer Institution, die aus staatlichen Geldern gezahlt wird. Und gleichzeitig versucht diese Person, die ihm zur Seite steht, zu verhindern, dass er abgeschoben wird. Weil normalerweise aus dem Land, aus dem er kommt, einfach abgeschoben wird. Weil das nicht als unsicheres Herkunftsland gilt. Und was auch zusätzlich für mich immer unverständlich und absurd ist, ist die Tatsache, dass wir von den Ämtern gegeneinander arbeiten. Dann kommen wir vom Jugendamt dorthin. Wir werden dafür bezahlt, dass wir dorthin kommen. Dass wir diese Pläne machen, gucken, wie entwickelt der junge Mann sich? Kann der für sich sorgen? Kann der kochen? Macht er seinen Schulabschluss? Wo will der bleiben? Dann gibt es noch eine staatliche Institution, die diesen Betreuer stellt. Vom Migrationsamt ab und zu. Oder auch von dieser Institution, wo er gerade untergebracht ist. Die schauen, schafft er sein Papierkram. Und ihm dann mit dem Papierkram hilft von einer dritten Behörde, die versucht, ihn wieder loszuwerden und ihn wieder abzuschieben. Das Ganze ist für mich unverständlich und völlig absurd. Dass wir einfach auch von der Behörde im Interesse des Kindes bzw. des jungen Mannes gegeneinander schon mal per se arbeiten müssen. Statt diesem Jungen, der einfach mit Feuer hier ist, zu sagen, wir brauchen dich, wunderbar, dass du hier bist, bitte bleib. Und wenn du bleibst, zahlen wir dir die Wohnung während deiner Ausbildung und am besten noch die Erstausstattung. Und dann sorgen wir dafür, dass du auch sofort hier übernommen wirst, weil wir einfach keine Leute haben. Und das ist für mich einfach eine Sache, die komplett unverständlich ist und von euch wie immer wunderbar und gut aufbereitet.
Ja, es gibt ja ungefähr 15 Millionen solcher Geschichten in Deutschland. Schon allein, weil ungefähr 300.000 polnische Frauenfamilien dabei helfen, irgendwie durch diese Pflegezeit zu kommen, bis die Alten sterben. Man muss es einfach mal so deutlich sagen. Und die haben ja letztens auch vom Arbeitsgericht dieses Urteil bekommen, dass da jetzt Mindestlohn gezahlt werden muss, was natürlich diese Familie nochmal besonders unter Druck und Stress setzt. Und dann haben wir solche Geschichten wie von Janik. Jemand möchte hier gerne pflegen. Hat sich diesen Beruf kennend trotzdem ausgesucht. Das hatten wir ja auch schon mal übersprochen, dass Menschen diesen Beruf kennenlernen. Und dann plötzlich, ah nee, das will ich jetzt doch nicht. Und so, dass selbst die Pflegepräsidentin, wie wir sie kurz nennen, gesagt hat, nee, jetzt lieber keine Dienstpflichtigen in die Pflege schicken, denn die stellen da nur fest, das ist hier gar nicht gut und sagen dann auch noch ihren Freunden Bescheid. Und Katzi Berger auf Twitter hat mich auch nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass bei Faznetz so ein Text erschien, wo der IFO-Arbeitsmarktexperte Stefan Sauer sagt, was zum Beispiel der Detlef Scheele von der Arbeitsagentur schon sagte und wahrscheinlich Andrea Nahles auch demnächst häufiger sagen wird, nämlich es scheiden in Deutschland pro Jahr bis zu 400.000 Menschen altersbedingt aus dem Erwerbsleben aus, als Neuer aus der Schule dazukommen. Ich würde sagen, ja, derzeit kann man so mit 400.000 rechnen, noch ein paar Jahre drauf, 2029 nehmen wir lieber 600.000, denn wir wollen ja realistisch bleiben. Und der Countdown läuft, um solche Leute wie Janeks hier beschreibt, mit Handkuss anzunehmen, aufzunehmen, ihnen noch Begrüßungsgeld zu zahlen und so. Weil am Ende irgendwann drückt der Schuh. Das sieht man immer wieder, wenn man auf diesen Konzerten ist, wie viele Leute da irgendwie bereit sind, für 8, 50 Euro ihr Bier zu kaufen. So, und wer für 8, 50 Euro ein Bier kauft, der bezahlt wahnsinnig gerne einfach nur Geld dafür, dass sich jemand um die Alten kümmert, statt es selbst tun zu müssen. Und dieses Potenzial, das wirklich zahlen zu wollen, muss ja mal entfesselt werden in Deutschland, damit solche Leute da eine Perspektive kriegen, die uns allen... Also, es gibt gar nicht mehr Win-win-win-Situationen als bei sowas, ja? Und dass da immer noch die Bürokratie so rein funkt, ist verrückt.
Fehlen Leute. Und ich würde gern noch einen Aspekt aufgreifen, den kafkaesken Aspekt dabei. Denn Janik hat ja jetzt beschrieben, dass die Ämter gegeneinander arbeiten. Das heißt, man hat von Staats- man hat von der Politik aus und durch die Kommunen und diese ganzen verschiedenen Verteilungen, man hat von der Politik aus ein Konstrukt geschaffen, bei dem man ein Konkurrenzverhältnis, ein scheinbares aufgebaut hat, zwischen den Ämtern, die sich gegenseitig bekämpfen für nichts. Also nur, um zu sagen, wir haben besonders viele abschieben können. Das ist unser Erfolg. Die wollen ja immer so viele dalassen. Da müssen wir also mindestens mal die Hälfte abschieben können. Es ist einfach ein vollkommen idiotisches Spiel. Wir werden ja heute über Gamification reden, das man dort errichtet hat, dass dann Leute dazu treibt, eigentlich jahrzehntelang Bullshit-Jobs nicht nur zu machen, sondern eigentlich Jobs zu machen, die die Gesellschaft in Deutschland verschlechtert und den Wohlstand mindert. Dafür sind die eigentlich von der Politik angestellt. Und das ist so absurd, wie diese Ämter dagegen die richtigen Leute arbeiten. Es ist etwas, was man wahrscheinlich, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das auflösen kann. Also es ist ja so, dass man da so ein Monster geschaffen hat, einen solchen Apparat geschaffen hat, der ja auch sich selbst dient in erster Linie. Also diese Leute sind ja auf diesen Positionen da, auch vor allem zur Selbsterhaltung. Das kennen wir aus vielen anderen Dingen. Und da, glaube ich, wird das ganz schwer. Da kann man eigentlich nur mit der großen politischen Ansage kommen und sagen, wir brauchen so viele Leute wie möglich, wie man auch bei den Bildungsministerien irgendwann mal gesagt hat, liebe Schulen, diese Abi-Prüfung, die muss schon so sein, dass alle eigentlich bestehen. Denn wir wollen viele Abiturienten haben. Und diese Ansage gab es ja, und genauso gab es die auch an Universitäten, weshalb da auch in der Regel in vielen Fächern niemand mehr durchfällt, weil das sozusagen die Ansage ist. Und ich glaube, diese Ansage muss dann einfach von der Politik kommen, und dann gibt es Strafe für jeden Beamten, der noch jemand abschiebt.
Genau, und das kann man ja zum Abschluss, bevor wir euch gleich sagen, was für tolles Lesen. In Deutschland haben wir spezielle Defizite, sowieso volkswirtschaftlich, also klar, wir überfliegen irgendwie, um es zu zitieren, Deutschland, Deutschland, über allen, Europa und so. Trotzdem haben wir so gewisse Defizite volkswirtschaftlicher Natur, die uns auch wirklich irgendwann so in den Hintern beißen werden. Merken wir jetzt noch nicht so ganz. Und wir haben auch Defizite bei der Lebensfreude. Und die Sachen fallen immer irgendwie so ein bisschen zusammen, beides. Und dann kommt immer die Frage, wenn so jemand ein Buch schreibt, oder sonst irgendwie, ja, was machen wir jetzt? Steht in deinem Buch jetzt die Lösung drin? Du hast doch das Problem schon mal auf dem Titel, sondern was ist denn jetzt die Lösung? Und die Lösung ist nicht, dass sich irgendwelche Privatleute hinsetzen und so grübeln und dann so eine Idee, so ein Programm irgendwie entwickeln, sondern es geht häufig darum, und hier eben auch neue Benchmarks einzuführen, nur alleine, dass man darüber spricht. Also wir brauchen viele Zuwanderer, da müssen wir ganz viel darüber reden, wie wir viele Zuwanderer kriegen. Und dann kommen irgendwelche Beiträge, wie von mir oder von dir, wo es dann nochmal heißt, das hat auch einen volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen. Da geht es nicht nur um, ach die armen Menschen und die Flüchtlinge oder so. Nein, es hat auch ganz funktionale Gründe. Das klingt dann manchmal ein bisschen kühl, aber führt in die richtige Richtung, denn dann haben wir einen Benchmark und auf den hin optimiert sich die Gesellschaft dann von alleine. Wir werden das gleich wieder in einem Buch lesen, wo auch nochmal gesagt wird, also der Kapitalismus, der legt sich über alles. Also da ist egal, was an Grundlage und so vorherrscht. Wenn man den einmal zulässt, dann legt er sich einfach über alles. Und darin liegt, finde ich, immer noch so eine Chance irgendwie. Man muss nur die Benchmarks richtig finden. Weg vom BIP und dann vielleicht so ein bisschen, jetzt sind wir ja schon auf dem Trip, dass wir uns bei der Energie mal Gedanken machen und da neue Benchmarks einführen und so Zielvorgaben. Und dann so, die politischen Programme kommen dann irgendwie schon über Grenzanpassungsmechanismen oder was auch immer. Neue Steuerformen, ja plötzlich gibt es Übergewinnsteuern und so ein Kram. Also in der Ansicht, man braucht einfach dieses große Gespräch und diese Problematisierung und Thematisierung dessen, worum es eigentlich geht. Und das haben wir hier von Janik gerade wieder gehört. Das ist so ein ganz konkreter Fall, wo wir ja schon immer drüber geflogen sind, um einfach die großen Zahlen zu nennen. Jetzt sind eher das einzelne Schicksal. Das gehört alles miteinander zusammen. Und dann hoffen wir einfach, wenn 17-mal Maibrit Illner darüber gesprochen hat, dass dann auch irgendein Politiker denkt, ah, da könnte ich auch mal um Unterstützung werben für ein Programm. Und dann sind alle sensibilisiert. Und wählen auch entsprechend.
Wir werden sehen. Lass mich noch einen Clip abspielen. Und zwar von Bloomberg Technology, dem Podcast, der ja immer so täglich über alles Mögliche aus dem Silicon Valley und sonst wo berichtet. Und da geht es um TikTok. Und mir war nicht klar, dass es diese Entwicklung genommen hat. Wir hören da mal rein. Das ist doch eine interessante Beobachtung, denn ich muss ja auch daran denken, dass es dieses Briefing vom Weißen Haus gab für die TikTokker, wie über den Ukraine-Krieg berichtet werden könnte, wie man Fake News erkennt und so weiter. Und dass offenbar diese Plattform immer mehr sich in ein Google für junge Leute verwandelt, dass sie sagen, ach ja, das ist ein Thema, das mich interessiert. Was gibt es denn dazu?
Ich verstehe das immer gar nicht mit diesem Suchen. Restaurant-Suche über Instagram, dass man dann irgendwie seinen Standort eintippt und sagt Essen. Und dann kriegt man so Essensfoto und sieht dann irgendwie, ah ja, das ist aus diesem und dem Restaurant. Da verstehe ich schon wieder die junge Generation nicht, was ich mir aber auch eingestehen kann, denn ich bin jetzt auch schon etwas älter und so. Aber ich bin noch voll Generation-Google-Suche natürlich.
Aber frag einfach mal deine Kinder, ob sie noch googeln oder schon TikToken. Ja, die dürfen ja nicht TikToken.
Außer mal der Freundin über die Schulter schauen oder so dabei, um zu sehen, dass es wirklich so bescheuert ist, wie der Papa immer sagt, hoffe ich. Ja, aber es scheint da so große Trends zu geben, die Google auch unter Druck setzen und so. Wer weiß. Ich habe noch verstanden, als es hieß, die Amazon, also Amazon macht jetzt die Produkt-Suchen, weil man dann gleich einen Preis und eine Kaufoption hat. Das hört man bei Google so nicht. Aber das sind wir auch so die letzte Generation.
Ja, sollen wir noch mal ganz kurz ganz groß denken. Wir haben ja in Deutschland mit Bauprojekten, wie zum Beispiel dem Stuttgarter Bahnhof, immer so unsere Probleme. Und da sagt man schon, ja, diese Großprojekte, die lassen sich ja nie so richtig realisieren. Oder wenn, dann dauert es zu lange und kostet zu viel. Und jetzt gibt es ein neues Projekt, das lanciert wurde in Saudi-Arabien. Man weiß ja, die müssen auch neu denken aufgrund des Klimawandels und so weiter. Und da wird jetzt etwas errichtet werden, das heißt The Line. Und du bist ja sehr für ein neues, modernes Wohnen. Und da wollte ich mal wissen, ob das jetzt so ist, wie du dir das vielleicht vorstellst.
Jetzt ist eine Revolution in der Zivilisation stattfand. Ergänze dich eine traditionelle Stadt und konsolidiere ihr Fortschritt, um die Natur zu schützen und zu verbessern. Die Line wird von 9 Millionen Residenzen heimkommen und wird mit einem Fortschritt von nur 34 km² gebaut. Die Lines-Kommunikationen sind in drei Dimensionen organisiert. Die Residenzen haben den ganzen Tag die Neuigkeiten innerhalb von 5 Minuten neuer Nachbarn.
Klingt natürlich alles sehr vielversprechend, aber ich finde, die Musik ist sehr überzeugend.
Also es ist so ein Image Video zu diesem Projekt.
700 Kilometer lang, also eine Line im Sinne von eine echte Leih, die sich so...
Es sieht aus auf diese Animationen wie die chinesische Mauer nur ein bisschen größer, hatte ich den Eindruck. Nein, aber ich glaube die chinesische Mauer ist dann am Ende doch größer, aber so sieht es aus. Nur dann breiter und dort gibt es dann verschiedene Stockwerke und ein, ich sage mal, Schienensystem, mit dem man da durchtransferiert wird, so dass man schnell von A nach B kommt und es gibt dann Orte, wo man arbeitet, wo man lebt und das ist alles integriert. Und das geht aber auch durch die Wüste hindurch. Also es spielt gar keine Rolle, wo The Line ist. Draußen ist alles dann mit Solar-Panels natürlich versehen. Da holt man dann die Energie her.
Also wie in diesem Science-Fiction-Film, mit so einem Ring im Weltraum und man hat so eine lange schmale...
Genau, aber hier, das wird einfach dann in Saudi-Arabien, soll es errichtet werden. Man weiß nicht, was das jetzt ist, ob es am Ende nur etwas ist, um Investoren anzulocken für irgendwas. Aber es ist zumindest doch interessant, dass ein solches Land jetzt sagt, wir machen mal so ein Megaprojekt und jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, wie das in Deutschland wäre. Wir diskutieren ja jetzt derzeit, können wir das 9-Euro-Ticket behalten? Er will nicht. Dann kommen die Grünen mit irgendwelchen Vorschlägen, ja mit 29 und 49 Euro und wenn dann zwischen den Bundesländern und ich weiß nicht was. Also da wird das ja dann noch mal zusammengeschrumpft, dass am Ende nicht mehr viel übrig bleibt. Und hier wird dann so ein Riesenvorschlag gemacht. Ich finde das erst einmal, auch wenn man natürlich Saudi-Arabien immer skeptisch gegenüber sein soll, bemerkenswert, dass so über das Wohnen nachgedacht wird.
Das stimmt.
Ja.
Intelligent Solutions create efficiency and year-round temperate microclimate with natural ventilation. Energy and water supplies are 100% renewable. The line is designed as a series of unique communities offering a wealth of amenities, providing equitable views and immediate access to the surrounding nature.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, als wir so in den Thales einstiegen und der Mann zu uns meinte, sie müssen das Ticket hier im Zug kaufen und der Zugmanager sitzt vorne im Bistro oder was auch immer und das sind fünf Waggons. Und ich dann, ok, dann geh ich da mal hin und Thales ist so ein bisschen enger gebaut. Ja, das ist nicht schön. Es gibt Gründe, warum man einen Zug in die Länge baut und nicht in die Höhe und in die Breite oder vielleicht sogar rund und so als Stadtkonzept finde ich das ein bisschen albern.
Ehrlich gesagt, da gibt es nur nicht, ob es geht, um möglichst viel Fläche für die Energie zu haben, also dass man wirklich so eine so eine so eine Mauer hat, weil das ja durch die Wüste durchgeht. Das ist übrigens dann viel länger als die chinesische Maul, die Chinesische Maul, habe gerade nachgeschaut, ist 20 Kilometer und hier, das wird ja 170 Kilometer lang sein.
Die chinesische Mauer ist auch tausende Kilometer lang. Also die Gesamte haben doch ganz China damals um mantelt, so dass man auch wirklich die Gebirgezüge vom Mond aussieht.
Also die chinesische Mauer, wo sie wirklich so als Mauerbegeber ist, ist 21 Kilometer, daher sonst ist natürlich die Grenze viel länger.
Das soll 170 Kilometer durch die Wüste. Also Wüste ist eine besondere Herausforderung, das muss man sagen. Vielleicht unterordnet man sich da wirklich dann solchen Gegebenheiten. Wenn man sowas plant, aber wer weiß. Ich wünsche viel Erfolg.
Aber wir müssen erst noch, bevor wir über die Texte sprechen, die wir dann im Salon verhandeln, sagen, dass es etwas Neues gibt für all jene, die einen Patreon-Account haben und bislang noch nicht den Salon abonniert haben, aber einen Patreon-Account haben und sich vielleicht auch dachten, ach, wären die nur bei Patreon, dann wäre alles für mich viel einfacher. Da müsste ich mir nicht noch mal extra ein Steady-Konto zulegen. Jetzt ist es möglich, wenn man Patreon ist, auch den Salon zu hören. Erklär uns, wie es geht.
Genau, und wir sagen ausdrücklich dazu, das sind Spielereien für diese kleinen Publikum-Segmente, die das nützlich finden, denn weiterhin bleibt Steady die erste Anlaufstelle, aus vielerlei Gründen. Dort ist es am billigsten, dort kriegt man seinen eigenen Feed. Man kriegt Kapitelmagen, man kriegt ein Cover-Bild für den Podcast und so weiter. Also alles, was drinsteckt, alles, was drinstecken kann im Salon, kriegt man im bei Steady. Patreon gibt es allerdings auch. Steady hat ja Patreon so ein bisschen nachgebaut. Das hat ja ganz lange keine richtige Rechnungsführung, die man in Deutschland Finanzamt einfach so vorlegen kann. Das hat sich aber jetzt geändert. Und sie ermöglichen eben auch Podcast Paywalls, also so, dass man da einfach bucht. Die Jahresmitgliedschaften, die Steady für uns so attraktiv und für euch so billig machen, gibt es da aber nicht so einfach. Da läuft gerade so ein Mail-Verkehr mit denen. Mal gucken, ich habe noch mal geschrieben, wie das dann genau aussieht und so. Aber dadurch ist es halt ein Monatspreis von 3 Euro, der auch jeden Monat belastet wird, was heißt, dass dann jeden Monat Zahlungsgebühren anfallen und so. Das kann bei Steady eben alles wunderbar umgehen. Aber für alle, die eh schon bei Patreon sind und da vielleicht Account-Sparsamkeit machen wollen, was ja auch immer ein guter Grund ist, die können einfach über Patreon. Wir verlinken das natürlich mit auf der Seite. Da gibt es dann auch einen Eigenfeed, wie bei Steady. Den kann man in seinem Podcatcher, in seinem Lieblings-Podcatcher einfach abonnieren und dann den Salon hören. Heute ist natürlich Generalprobe ein. Also der letzte Salon ist schon drin. Nur bei Steady und dann Steady auch über Spotify und so weiter gibt es das ganze Archiv. Das müsste man auch bei Patreon wieder mit der Hand als Handarbeit nachpflegen. Das würde ich tatsächlich mal umgehen, weil wir ja eben das Steady-Angebot haben, da einfach all in, was die Sachen angeht. Aber es gibt jetzt halt auch Patreon.
Genau, und Apple gibt es nach wie vor auch noch, aber Steady bleibt unser Favorit. Und wir sprechen heute über ein Buch, das uns erklärt, wie wir lieben und Sex haben in digitalen Zeiten, im Internet mit Sexrobotern und so weiter. Von Alfie Bown, Dreamlovers, The Gamification of Relationships. Und ich habe eine Frage, die das Buch mir beantworten wird wahrscheinlich. Oder beziehungsweise wir müssen uns fragen, ob diese Frage beantwortet wird. Und zwar, was ist es denn eigentlich, was wir bekommen von den Dating Apps, von den Porno-Seiten und den anderen Toys, die man so kaufen kann? Geben die uns, was wir begehren? Oder stellen die erst unser Begehren her?
Ich habe es auch unter einer Fragestellung gelesen, die uns ja alle schon seit einer Weile, 5, 6 Jahre, wenigstens beeindruckt, wenn ich wirklich restlos fanziniert, nämlich, dass die Politik so leidenschaftlich geworden ist, dass wir uns immer all in verteidigen, Identitätspolitik. Wir können schon gar keine Meinung mehr akzeptieren, weil wir die ganze Person schon ablehnen, die uns irgendwas sagt. Und das geht ja so weit, dass man sich über die Politik hinaus als Thema in Familien zerstreitet. Ja, und dieses Buch gibt einen guten Kontrapunkt dazu, nämlich zu fragen, was ist in der Zeit mit der Liebe passiert, wo ja eigentlich die Leidenschaft zu verorten ist? Und wie ist dieser Zusammenhang von Politik und Liebe? Da finde ich, gibt es ganz gute Antworten, auch wenn du mir eben schon angeteased hast, dass du das Buch ansonsten gar nicht so gut fandest, was mich wiederum überrascht.
Ich bin aber jetzt wiederum überrascht, dass du es offenbar viel besser findest. Das wird interessant, aber ich glaube, wir können eine tolle Debatte führen über ganz viel. Was mich interessiert, denn es ist tatsächlich so ein Stein des Anstoßes, dass man über ganz viel diskutieren muss. Auch um Fragen der Willensfreiheit muss es gehen, inwieweit man programmieren kann, inwieweit man wirklich so eine Desire Revolution, also eine Begehrensrevolution anzetteln kann, was hier vorgeschlagen wird. Oder inwieweit auch wirklich die Liebe etwas wahnsinnig Privatistisches ist. Und wirklich etwas Unpolitisches in einer Weise, sodass es sich aus der Politik entfernt. Das können wir sehr gut diskutieren. Was hast du noch für unsere Frage?
Genau, und ich wollte noch dazu sagen, vielleicht lohnt es sich häufiger zu sagen, was wir da eigentlich lesen. Also falls ihr überlegt, sollte ich mir das im Salon buchen. Ihr könnt doch erst das Buch lesen. Dreamlovers von L. Alfie Brown heißt das. Ich lese ansonsten Sachen, die mich diesmal wirklich über die Salon-Ausgabe hinaus interessieren. Zum einen Transsexualität am Beispiel von Elliot Page. Wir kennen ihn aus Juno und Inception zum Beispiel, damals noch als Frau. Und er ist ja nun eine Person, von der wir sagen können, ökonomisch erst mal abgesichert und so weiter. Er hat wahrscheinlich überall auf der Welt Freunde und weiß, wo man zu Hause ist. Und dadurch kommt diese Erklärung, was ist mit dem eigenen Körpergefühl und so weiter, noch mal deutlicher hervor. Und er hat so eine Art Selbstgespräch geführt für eine amerikanische Esquire-Ausgabe, die auf Deutsch vorliegt und in die wir einfach mal so ein bisschen von oben nach unten durchgehen, weil da sind ganz interessante zum Sport, unser Mode und so weiter. Alles, was so Körperbezug hat drin. Dann bei Futurama wurde vor 15 Jahren oder vor 13 Jahren ein mathematisches Problem gelöst, das die Autoren selber aufgestellt haben. Also aus dem Plot heraus. Sie sitzen albernd da und schreiben eine Folge und stellen dann fest, oh, wir haben uns hier grad verrannt und ach, zum Glück habe ich in Mathematik promoviert. Also lösen wir es jetzt auch mal ordentlich auf und machen nicht Halligalli draus. Super interessant, weil es da auch Geschichten von den Simpsons gibt, wo die das auch schon so machen. Außerdem hat die New York Times mal über die neue Bücherverbrennung geschrieben. Die Orte, die bislang als da kannst du hingehen und diskutieren galten, nämlich vor allem Bibliotheken, insbesondere von Schulen, High Schools und so weiter, sind jetzt Kriegsgebiet geworden, wo auch gerne mal die Proud Boys antanzen und naja, gucken, wer da so die Geschäfte führt und wenn man Maßregeln sollte. Und außerdem gibt es in der New York Times vom August jetzt schon, aber egal, einen Text, eine neue Studie, also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, ich habe Lieblingsökonom, aber Raj Chetty, ein Jahrgang 79, unglaublich junger Professor aus Harvard, hat mal wieder eine Megastudie vorgelegt, schon häufiger über Nachbarschaften und so weiter gesprochen, diesmal geht es um Freundschaft und den ökonomischen Benefit, wenn man Freunde hat, die vielleicht ein bisschen besser verdienen. Unglaublich bahnbrechend finde ich zum Thema Zusammenhalt und so weiter, sollten wir in Deutschland dringend lesen, so wie alles vom Chetty, also seid gespannt.
Ich habe auch eine Studie von Henning Eichler, das ist ein Projekt der Otto Brenner Stiftung, und da wird gefragt, befinden sich ARD und ZDF im Bann der Algorithmen? Wir wissen, die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen sind im Netz stark vertreten, auch durch das Jugendprogramm Funk, und hier wurden qualitative Interviews geführt mit Menschen hinter den Kulissen, und das ist doch recht aufschlussreich, oder in gewisser Weise auch, wenn man einen eher pessimistischen Blick hat, nicht so verwunderlich, was sich dann dabei herausstellt. Darüber wird zu reden sein außerdem ein interessanter Artikel bzw. ein Interview, darüber, wie China Hollywood-Filme verändert, und zwar auf zum Teil ganz eigenartige Weise, also Dinge, auf die man gar nicht kommt. Erich Schwarzel hat ein Buch darüber geschrieben und ein Interview gegeben, jetzt, wie man sich das vorstellen muss. Das ist wirklich überraschend. Dann, wie schon angekündigt, ein Text aus der Kulturszene Die Leute sollen wiederkommen von Rocco Schamoni. Also nicht jemand, der jetzt aus der Oper oder so ist. Dann einen Erzählungsband Brauchbare Menschen von Magdalena Schrefel. Sie schreibt vor allem über moderne Arbeitswelten, auch dann über Migranten, Polen, die sagen, ja, wir kommen wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr nicht mehr, jetzt kommt vielleicht noch Ukraine, aber dann ist auch Schluss hier. Es geht in diesen Erzählungen sehr viel um das Zwischenmenschliche, um eigenartige Kommunikationen. Eine Erzählung, die ich ein bisschen näher vorstellen, da geht es um den Vater, eine Tochter, die mit ihrem Vater nur noch telefonisch selten kommuniziert. Und ich hatte es schon angekündigt, ich habe eine Zeitschrift aus dem neurechten Milieu gelesen. Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt keine Empfehlung. Nicht, dass es dann bald heißt, Wolfgang empfiehlt jetzt schon neurechte Publikationen. Aber es lohnt sich, da mal reinzuschauen. Ich will einen Artikel besonders vorstellen, wie die neuen Rechten auf das Thema Klimawandel reagieren. Und da kann einem auch noch mal Angst und Bange werden. Denn es ist keineswegs so, dass man hier eine Publikation hat, wo irgendwie steht, ne, das gibt es gar nicht, wir können so weitermachen. Sondern nein, es wird alles anerkannt, dass es ein großes, großes Problem gibt. Nur man kann sich denken, die Lösung, die davor gestanden wird, sieht ein wenig anders aus.
Sehr gut. Na dann, stürzen wir uns mal in den Salon und sagen bis gleich.